at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking no question magnetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail or
any other design i recommend checking
out 99 designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I use them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one New York Times best seller
I've also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 9 million dollar upgrade on your
first design so check it out 99 designs
com forward slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by wealthfront and this
is a very unique sponsor wealthfront is
a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront com forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it and here's
why the
value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth front that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
just take a look see what portfolio they
would create for you and you can use
that information however you want
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show this is an in-between
asad of sorts
it is not a long-form interview but
rather it is an excerpt it is one of my
favorite letters from Seneca a mere two
thousand or so years old and it explores
a number of different practical
philosophies that I encourage you to
digest now the first few paragraphs
might seem a little off the reservation
but then we get quickly to what you
could call the Fight Club philosophy
meaning of course the bar conversation
the things you own end up owning you so
I try that again the things you own end
up owning you I need more caffeine and
the exploration thereof I think is
extremely valuable if you want more of
these letters you can check them out in
the Tao of Seneca it is a compilation
that I put together and you can find
those volumes at audible.com forward
slash Tim's books that's audible.com
forward slash Tim's books where you can
find my book club which includes I think
seven or eight other books that have had
a huge impact on my life so without
further adieu please enjoy letter 42 on
values by Seneca the younger
letter 42 on values has that friend of
yours already made you believe that he
is a good man and yet it is impossible
in so short a time for one either to
become good or be known as such do you
know what kind of man I now mean when I
speak of a good man I mean one of the
second grade like your friend for one of
the first class perhaps springs into
existence like the Phoenix only once in
five hundred years and it is not
surprising either that greatness
develops only at long intervals fortune
often brings into being commonplace
powers which are born to please the mob
but she holds up for our approval that
which is extraordinary by the very fact
that she makes it rare this man however
of whom you spoke is still far from the
state which he professes to have reached
and if he knew what it meant to be a
good man he would not yet believe
himself such perhaps he would even
despair of his ability to become good
but you say he thinks ill of evil men
well so do evil men themselves and there
is no worse penalty for Vice than the
fact that it is dissatisfied with itself
and all its fellows but he hates those
who make an uncovered use of great power
suddenly acquired I retort that he will
do the same thing as soon as he acquires
the same powers in the case of many men
their vices being powerless escaped
notice although as soon as the persons
in question have become satisfied with
their own strength the vices will be no
less daring than those which prosperity
has already disclosed these men simply
lack the means whereby they may unfold
their wickedness similarly one can
handle even a poisonous snake while it
is stiff with cold the poison is not
lacking it is merely numbed into
inaction
in the case of many men their cruelty
ambition and indulgence only lack the
favor of fortune to make them dare
crimes that would match the worst that
their wishes are the same you will in a
moment discover in this way give them
the power equal to their wishes do you
remember how when you declared that a
certain person was under your influence
I pronounced him fickle in a bird of
passage and said that you held him not
by the foot but merely by a wing who as
I mistaken you grasped him only by a
feather he left it in your hands and
escaped you know what an exhibition he
afterwards made of himself before you
how many of the things he attempted were
to recoil upon his own head he did not
see that in endangering others he was
tottering to his own downfall he did not
reflect how burdensome were the objects
which he was bent upon attaining even if
they were not superfluous therefore with
regard to the objects which we pursue
and for which we strive with great
effort we should note this truth either
there is nothing desirable in them or
the undesirable is preponderance some
objects are superfluous others are not
worth the price we pay for them but we
do not see this clearly and we regard
things as free gifts when they really
cost us very dear our stupidity may be
clearly proved by the fact that we hold
that buying refers only to the objects
for which we pay cash and we regard as
free gifts the things for which we spend
our very cells these we should refuse to
buy if we were compelled to given
payment for them our houses or some
attractive and profitable estate but we
are eager to attain them at the cost of
anxiety of danger and have lost honor
personal freedom and time so true it is
that each man regards nothing as cheaper
than himself
let us therefore act in all our plans
and conduct just as we are accustomed to
act whenever we approach a huckster who
has certain wares for sale let us see
how much we must pay for that which we
crave very often the things that cost
nothing cost us the most heavily I can
show you many objects the quest and
acquisition of which have rested freedom
from our hands we should belong to
ourselves if only these things did not
belong to us I would therefore have you
reflect thus not only when it is a
question of gain but also when it is a
question of loss this object is bound to
perish yes it was a mere extra you will
live without it
just as easily as you have lived before
if you have possessed it for a long time
you lose it after you have had your fill
of it if you have not possessed it long
then you lose it before you have become
wedded to it you will have less money
yes and less trouble less influence yes
and less Envy look about you and note
the things that drive us mad which we
lose with a flood of Tears you will
perceive that it is not the loss that
troubles us with reference to these
things but a notion of loss no one feels
that they have been lost but his mind
tells him that it has been so he that
owns himself has lost nothing but how
few men are blessed with ownership of
self
Sara well hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday the vet
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
take the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it and here's
why the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally art great investing
is a marathon not a sprint and little
things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show is because I use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront yet
because I'm not allowed to here's the
deal they wanted to sponsor this podcast
but because of SEC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if
you decide to open an account but just
start with seeing the portfolio that
they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
tip
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail or
any other design I recommend checking
out 99 designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I use them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one York Times best seller I've
also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from a fellow Tim Ferriss
show listeners at 99 designs com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free and $99 upgrade on your first
design so check it out 99 designs com
forward slash Tim and until next time
thank you for listening
you